you have uh do you have a son or a
daughter I got a son his name trophy his
name's trophy yeah [__] great name
for a kid I'm gang he five months five
months old shout out to Trophy what is
has fatherhood changed you at
all
uh yeah in what way yeah because like I
got to get back home to my son so
instead of like doing stupid [__] not
thinking I got to like you know I'm
living for him now so everything I do is
got to be like for him type [__] instead
of just moving sloppy in the streets I
got to like think about him like I got
to raise my son yeah like the goal
should always be to get back home to
your kid right yeah for sure are you
like instead of like you just kidless
and you just out here just doing
whatever like 100% And and they don't
got [__] to lose exactly are you
changing shitty diapers yeah I did a
couple times but I let his mom really
deal with that [__] mom's dealing with
the [__] yeah I know this mom deal with
that [__] I had my kid when he was a
baby shat on me on accident he was like
had diarrhea and it he done pissed on me
a couple times threw up on me all the
time yeah the puk's going to happen the
baby the baby milk puke yeah I'd have
been h i really put that [__] on he
didn't threw up right on it there I'm
like [__] take it off yeah it's crazy
how's your how's are you and uh his mom
have a like a healthy relationship n
hell no man that [__] toxic as a
[__] bro [__] the D sh what's
her ethnicity black she's black okay
yeah I got a Mexican baby mama who's a
psychopath yeah her yeah she crazy as a
[__] when toxic how though like
she just like crazy cuz she want you she
do crazy [__] like she just know my
trigger points cuz so I be out whatever
on the dayie she just like trigger a
[__] bro for having me like off my
Square cuz homies but now now was like
now I'm being like way better can she
send you a text and ruin your mood on
the dead that type of [__] cuz she used
to do that [__] she'll do that [__]
she'll know you're out doing some [__]
and she'll like I'm ruin his [__]
night and then shoot you some [__] yeah
or post some stupid [__] on the dead
homies that me and her only know about
like on a dead homies posting little
stupid [__] on [__] like just dumb [__]
but yeah [__] like that though that [__]
be happen send me dumb what would be
like a something you I mean you don't
have to share but something that you
could share was like a trigger of yours
where she would just [__] like put
the knife in uh when she call me a dead
beat oh that's not dead homies I hate
that [__] I'll be doing it up for my son
cuz yeah and it's like you also are are
obviously you have a career that's
flourishing right now but N I made her I
made her uh make a promise cuz I never
do that [__] again gu what she ain't
been doing a l cuz you already know I do
it up I do whatever for him so yeah
you're supporting your kid right yeah
that just yeah yeah that just one of
them though calling me a dad but she got
she a lot of low trigger points but like
I said I've been getting better at her
now though I'll just be ignoring her now
cuz she been getting better at like what
do she work or does she just take care
of the kid and you you not yeah she
worked okay G yeah well [__] man like
you know her mom help us like watching
you can't call somebody a dead beat bro
yeah especially if they ain't a dead
especially if they not one that [__]
just like I get it if they're a dead
beat I get it but like it's it's it's
cuz she she sees what's happening she
wants to like you know yeah yeah yeah
she went you to herself bro that too but
like she know she had it but she like
blew it on so she blew it so you guys
are not dating anymore you guys are just
no you know parenting co-parenting yeah
hey co-parenting is important especially
like listen when your kid starts to get
older she got to kill all that toxic
[__] cuz the K she straight though she
she straight on gam that's good she stra
she did a lot for me that's what's up
man um for you like obviously you've had
a pretty interesting 12 months but
really the last 6 seven months things
have really picked up for you like
um are you feeling that now are you kind
of feeling like okay because I've heard
you have a reputation that you're crazy
I don't know if you know that about
yourself that's what they say lot a
couple of people like homie's crazy he's
really like he really crazy you I'm
crazy I I've heard that um but I'm
wondering like for you obviously 5
months ago you have a kid your rap
career is flourishing like crazy are you
feeling like oh [__] like I really got
some like lifechanging momentum that
could go you know we've I mean you've
seen a lot of people get hot and go away
get hot die you know what I'm saying
like um are you kind of like feeling
like finally like oh [__] you know what
this is for real like this this rap
shit's really working out for me yeah
hell yeah lately I've been feeling like
that like I've been feeling like a real
artist Le the attention I've been
getting the type of people that been
tapping in now like hell yeah this [__]
like different who's tapped in with you
that you were like oh [__] like this is
crazy I was like oh uh estg estg who wed
who was sitting in this chair and stood
up and walked off yeah yeah he stood up
and got he didn't like the fact that I
was you probably said buk what you say
bro I asked him what he thought about
aliens yeah and then I asked him about
his football career and he [__] stood
up and walked off football career BR he
was no he played football he went to the
NFL combine he was like a linebacker at
I think Eastern Kentucky he was like a
like he could have went to the league
yeah he probably I don't think he W I
don't I don't know I just thought the
football thing was like a there's video
of him like [__] in press conferences
like [__] people up on the football
field so I was just asking him about it
and he was like what's that got to do
with my music and I was like
but it's got a lot it's you br I'm
asking about you dog like you know what
I'm saying like yeah D yeah he probably
yeah you wanted to talk about ESG tapped
in yeah he's dope I love his music yeah
he wants to work yeah he told me to send
him something oh that' be hard yeah that
[__] crazy any of the like West Coast LA
ogs hit you at
all
uh no not no West Coast OG's matter of
fact on the day homie somebody uh on
[__] one of my old managers did tell me
one of this one of them old [__] he
got a own name too cuz I forget right
now cuzz I be smoking weed and [__] on
Old like yeah one him back from one of
them Corr like type erors cuz one of
them [__] he they want to work me but
I'm like I'm sporty all that [__] a't is
before your era yeah I respect it though
on the day homies I respect the OG's on
like Snoop hits you Snoop you know
that's different you know that's leg
that's Snoop that's Sno on the day
homies but a lot of that [__] I'm just
like know don't be feeling ain't my
error but I respect OG's though um for
people who aren't from LA obviously you
have rolling 40s 4S tattooed on your on
your lip people who can't read it um I
think that the most famous [__] from La
in the last decade is probably nip who
is you know obviously is affiliated with
the rolling 60s yeah um are you guys
like very what's the difference between
the rolling 40s rolling 60s and well
it's kind of like [__] it's kind of like
the same thing like the' 40s well in LA
and the hoods like that's going to be
like the closest hoods going to get to
like damn and near being the same it's
like only a couple shits off from us
being different like we like anything
that's got like rolling in front of it
it's kind of like you n cuz like rolling
30s rolling hundreds all type of [__]
but just the 40s and the 60s cuz we just
like we just like it just being always
you guys kind of move in the same
direction type [__] on gang so we just
like all acted like 40s and the 60s on
game same Ops same Ops that makes sense
okay um was nip somebody who you grew up
like you know looking up to not
necessarily looking up to cuz but I had
like a on the dead homies a couple uh
nip songs I used to play on gang I ain't
gonna lie I play I I listen to C more
after C fyp but I think the world was
like that I mean I mean I've known nip
since 09 he was on my show in 09 but
like you know unfortunately he passed
away and then people really gave him the
flowers he deserved after he died it
made me like look at certain [__]
different and pay attention to his
lyrics a little bit more on gang but
like y I had a couple songs like that
that was hot though that I used to play
while he was
alive I didn't like you know look up to
him though but he was like on a d on Me
a Genius though no for sure one of the
greats man I was
I wonder too like it's it's crazy cuz I
feel like um him passing the way he did
like you know was such a tragic
situation cuz he was at home like for
you do you see [__] like that and like
make sure you're kind of like very very
careful cuz now you got a lot of eyes on
you bro yeah hell yeah on the day homies
bro i' be like paranoid cuz i' be
already like moving a certain way though
on the day homies I don't like being a
certain place too long I be like in and
out on like cuz I already know [__] like
that can happen I already know and
you're very recognizable very recogniz
everybody already know your face tattoos
are very mean people people see you know
you you don't know them they can [__]
around C they can be like an innocent
looking type [__] you don't even know
see you like oh that's X4 [__] around
text tex4 here you don't even know crazy
[__] like that so you're always in and
out of places yeah you got to be in and
out bro you a die or [__] around in up
been situation where you got to kill a
[__] now you figh life